RESEARCH, STILL TOO MUCH IS
UNKNOWN.
IT'S AMAZING.
>> YOU BET, THANKS JOHN.
>> THANK, YOU SIR.
>> VIRGINIA SEEMS A REALLY A
CHRISTMAS PARTY AT DOWNING
STREET.
IF VIDEO SHOWS STAFFERS AT
NUMBER 10, NOT AT THE ACTUAL
PARTY, BUT RATHER DAYS AFTER
THE ALLEGED EVENT, LAUGHING AND
JOKING ABOUT HOW TO EXPLAIN THE
GATHERING TO ANYONE FINDS OUT.
A SENIOR RESIDING WITHIN HOURS
OF THE VIDEO, MADE IT PUBLIC,
CALLS A GROWING LOUDER FROM THE
PRIME MINISTER TO STEP DOWN AS
WELL.
BORIS JOHNSON HAS APOLOGIZED.
HE HAS ORDERED AN INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION, REPUTEDLY
INSISTING THAT THERE WAS NO
PARTY AT DOWNING STREET A YEAR
AGO, WHEN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY WAS UNDER STRICT
LOCKDOWN.
CNN SALMA ABDELAZIZ HAS THE
LATEST NOW, REPORTING IN FROM
LONDON.
>> ALLEGRA STRATTON, SPOKESMAN
FOR DOWNING STREET, BECAME A
HOUSEHOLD NAME OVERNIGHT IN THE
UK.
ON WEDNESDAY, SHE RESIGNED ON
HER DOORSTEP.
>> MY REMARKS SEEM TO MAKE
LAUGH AT THE RULES.
RULES THAT PEOPLE WERE DOING
EVERY DAY.
THAT WAS NEVER MY INTENTION.
>> THE SENIOR BRITISH
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL MADE
HEADLINES, APPEARING TO MOCK
COVID RULES, AND JOKING ABOUT A
CHRISTMAS PARTY LAST YEAR.
>> THIS PARTY WAS A BOOSTERS
MEETING?
AND WE WERE NOT SOCIALLY
DISTANT.
>> IF TRUE, IT WOULD BE A
BRAZEN VIOLATION OF COVID
RESTRICTIONS.
THIS VIDEO, OBTAINED BY CNN
AFFILIATE, ITV, SHOWS AIDES
REPORTING FOR A BRIEFING, 4
DAYS AFTER THE ALLEGED PARTY.
BUT WHILE DOWNING STREET STAFF
GIGGLED ON THE VIDEO ABOUT
CHEESE AND CRACKERS, THE UK WAS
IN THE GRIPS OF A DEADLY RISE
OF COVID-19 CASES.
SAW FUEL WAS CARING FOR HER
ELDERLY FATHER THAT DAY.
SHE SAYS SHE CONTRACTED
CORONAVIRUS DURING THE
CHRISTMAS PERIOD, AND MADE IT
DIED OF THE VIRUS.
>> --
I WAS ABLE TO ACTUALLY BE WITH
MY DAD, WHEN HE DIED.
ME AND MY MOM, MY BROTHER, WERE
ABLE TO BE.
I CONSIDER A HUGE PRIVILEGE,
BECAUSE MANY OTHER MEMBERS
DIDN'T HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
>> ON DECEMBER 18TH ALONE, THE
DAY THE DOWNING STREET PARTY
ALLEGEDLY TOOK PLACE, MORE THAN
500 PEOPLE WERE REPORTED DEAD,
FROM COVID-19 IN THE UK.
>> WE SHOULD START LEAVING NOW!
>> AND THIS IS HOW POLICE
HANDLED OTHER FESTIVE
GATHERINGS, CRACKING DOWN AND
HANDING OUT FINES.
FOR DAYS, THE PRIME MINISTER
MAINTAINS THAT NO PARTY EVEN
TOOK PLACE.
>> ALL GUIDANCE WAS FOLLOWED,
COMPLETELY.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
ALL THE GUIDELINES WERE
OBSERVED --
>> ON WEDNESDAY, THE PRIME
MINISTER TOLD THAT HE WOULD
LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION, BUT
ADMITTED NO WRONGDOING.
>> I WAS ALSO FURIOUS TO SEE
THAT --
BUT I REPEAT, THE CHESAPEAKE
LAYER THAT I HAVE BEEN
REPEATEDLY ASSURED, SINCE THESE
ALLEGATIONS EMERGED.
BUT THERE WAS NO PARTY, AND
THAT NO COVID RULES WERE
BROKEN.
>> SO THE BRITISH PEOPLE PUT
THE HEALTH OF OTHERS ABOUT
THEMSELVES, AND FOLLOWED THE
RULES.
ISN'T THE PRIME MINISTER
ASHAMED THAT HIS DOWNING STREET
COULDN'T DO THE SAME?
>> THE DAY AFTER THE ALLEGED
PARTY, BORIS JOHNSON,
EFFECTIVELY CANCELED CHRISTMAS
FOR THE ENTIRE NATION, LIMITING
GATHERINGS.
2 DAYS LATER, MOST OF THE UK
WAS BACK UNDER RESTRICTIONS,
ESSENTIALLY A FULL LOCKDOWN.
NOW, AS THE COUNTRY ONCE AGAIN
IS RIDING A VARIANT, OMICRON,
MANY ARE ASKING IF THE PRIME
MINISTER HAS THE MORAL
AUTHORITY TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
SALMA ABDELAZIZ, CNN, LONDON.
>> AND EUROPEAN AFFAIRS
COMMENTATOR, THOMAS, IS WITH US
FROM SWEDEN.
DOMINIC, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK, YOU JOHN.
>> SO THERE'S A LITTLE MORE
FROM BORIS JOHNSON, AT
WEDNESDAYS QUESTION IN
PARLIAMENT.
>> I UNDERSTAND AND SHARE THE
ANGER UP AND DOWN THE COUNTRY
AT SEEING NUMBER 10 STAFF,
SEEMING TO MAKE LIGHT OF
LOCKDOWN MEASURES.
AND I COULD UNDERSTAND HOW
INFURIATING IT MUST BE TO THINK
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SETTING THE RULES HAVE NOT BEEN
FOLLOWING THE RULES.
>> AND THAT'S THE POINT.
PUTTING ASIDE ALL THE POLITICS
OF THE SCALE, SEEMS TO BE
DAMAGING TO THE PUBLIC'S TRUST
IN THIS GOVERNMENT, JUST AS
TOUGH FOR PANDEMIC GUIDELINES
ARE VAGUE INTRODUCED.
IT'S A CASE OF DON'T DO WHAT I
DO, JUST DO AS I SAY, RIGHT?
>> YES, THAT IS BASICALLY
SUMMING IT UP, JOHN.
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED OVER THE
PAST 2 YEARS IT'S THAT
COMPETENT, INSISTENT MESSAGING
FROM THE LABORATORIES HAS BEEN
ACTUALLY CRUCIAL IN THE GROWTH
AND THE DISSEMINATION OF THE
VIRUS.
AND WE HAVE GREAT SUCCESS
EXAMPLES IN PLACES LIKE FINLAND,
FOR EXAMPLE, AND NEW ZEALAND.
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE,
WE DO KNOW THAT IN AREAS WHERE
YOU'VE HAD COMPETENT LEADERSHIP,
AND I TAKE GERMANY AS AN
EXAMPLE, THAT HAS NOT ALWAYS
WORKED OUT IN THE BEST WAY.
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW FOR SURE IS
THAT AND COMPETENT LEADERSHIP,
AND CONSISTENT MESSAGING, HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO WITH --
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THE UK NOW,
WITH OVER 150,000 DEATHS, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT THERE IS
A CORRELATION BETWEEN THE LIES
AND THEN MISHANDLING OF THIS,
AND THE INCONSISTENT MESSAGING
OF BORIS JOHNSON GOVERNMENT.
BUT WE COULD JUST HOPE THE
BRITISH PEOPLE ARE BEING
INCREASINGLY RESOURCEFUL IN
TAKING HOLD OF THESE MEASURES,
AND NOT WAITING FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE THESE,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, THIS
MESSAGING DOESN'T MEAN THAT
IT'S GOING TO DISCONTINUE TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THOSE
PEOPLE, THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
OF BEING MISLED AND UNDERSERVED
BY THIS GOVERNMENT.
>> WELL, NOW YOU GET TO THE
POLITICS, AND FOR THAT, HERE IS
SOME MORE FROM THE LEADER OF
THE LABOR OPPOSITION.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> NO ONE WAS DREAMING OFF AS
ZOOM CHRISTMAS.
TURKEY DINNERS FOR ONE, GIFTS
EXCHANGED AT SERVICE STATIONS.
BUT THE VIRUS WAS OUT OF
CONTROL.
489 PEOPLE DIED OF COVID, ON
THE DAY OF THE DOWNING STREET
PARTY.
>> LAST, YEAR WHEN THOUSANDS OF
FINES WERE BEING WRITTEN FOR
REACHING COVID RESTRICTIONS ON
GATHERINGS, THIS WAS THE
CHRISTMAS, WHICH BORIS JOHNSON
CANCELED.
BUT HE SEEMED TO GET SOME
CREDIT FOR MAKING THE TOUGH
CAUSE.
IS HE --
HAS HE SUBMITTED AND NARRATIVE
OF THE ROOF OF EVERYONE ELSE?
>> YES, AND I THINK THAT THAT
HAS BEEN THE --
I THINK THAT FOR THE LEADERSHIP,
AND FOR A CERTAIN KIND OF
ENTITLED LEADER, WHICH IS
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
WHAT IS SO STRIKING ABOUT THIS,
THOUGH, IS THAT THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING NEW ABOUT THIS.
I MEAN, DOMINIC CUMMINGS, CAME
PUBLIC, AND TALKED ABOUT THE
GROWTH MISHANDLING, THE
IGNORANCE OF BORIS JOHNSON'S
ADMINISTRATION, THE CORRUPTION
SCANDALS AND GO AND SO ON.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THIS IS A
PRIME MINISTER WHO IS
ESSENTIALLY PAYING TO OFFICE ON
THE HEELS OF MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN, OF LYING TO THE
BRITISH PEOPLE ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF BREXIT AND SO ON.
AND ENDED UP ESSENTIALLY
WINNING AN ISSUE ON A SINGLE
ISSUE.
THIS IS NEVER BEEN A GOVERNMENT
THAT HAS BEEN ABOUT POLICY,
ABOUT TRANSFORMING THE
SITUATION AND IMPROVING PEOPLES
LIVES, AND HAVING A SENSE OF
ENTITLEMENT, WHICH IS
REFLECTIVE IN ALL THE BEHAVIOR
PATTERNS OF THIS PARTICULAR
GOVERNMENT.
AND YET, IT'S STILL SUCCEEDS IN
HOLDING ON TO POWER.
>> BUT THERE IS GROWING
CRITICISM NOW OF JOHNSON AND
THE LEADERSHIP FROM WITHIN HIS
OWN PARTY, THIS LEAKED VIDEO,
IN DEFENSE, IT'S CATASTROPHIC.
A RECENT POLL JUST CAME OUT,
THE MAJORITY BELIEVING THE
PRIME MINISTER SHOULD ACTUALLY
RESIGN.
AND A 3RD ARE CONCERNED THAT
VOTERS WILL FEEL THE SAME.
ASSUMING THIS CONTROVERSY DOES
NOT GET ANY WORSE, WILL JOHNSON
SURVIVE, AND WHY WOULD ANYONE
AS HUMAN WON'T GET ANY WORSE?
YEAH, AND WHY WOULD THEY NOT
ASSUME?
IT'S NOT A CHAPTER IN THE BORIS
JOHNSON PRIME MINISTER SHIP.
WHAT'S ALSO ABSOLUTELY OBSESSED
ORDINARY, BACK TO THE PREVIOUS
POINT THAT I MADE, IT SEEMS TO
BE OVERWHELMING VOTING PUBLIC
THAT BORIS JOHNSON'S PRIVATE
BEHAVIOR, HIS INSTANT MESSAGING,
AND SO, ON OUR SECONDARY TO THE
FACT THAT HE DELIVERED
BREAKFAST, SECOND TO THE FACT
THAT HE DELIVERED THIS MASSIVE
MAJORITY FOR THE CONSERVATIVE
PARTY.
AT THIS STAGE THE OPPOSITION
ITSELF REMAINS DIVIDED AND
SEEMS INCAPABLE OF MOUNTING
SOME KIND OF OPPOSITION TO
BORIS JOHNSON THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY UNDERMINED HIM.
AROUND HIM IN THE SORT OF
DANGEROUS WATERS HE ESSENTIALLY
SERVES AT THE WILL OF THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY AT THIS
STAGE.
IT WOULD BE UP TO THEM TO MAKE
A DECISION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
TO REMOVE HIM.
ONCE AGAIN HE DOESN'T DELIVER
THIS MASSIVE MAJORITY.
THEY ARE IN CONTROL.
THEY SEEM TO BE, AT THIS STAGE,
UNTOUCHABLE.
WHEN THE FALL COMES IT WILL BE
RAPID, BUT THERE IS NO REASON
TO BELIEVE AT THIS PARTICULAR
STAGE THAT THIS LATEST CHAPTER
WILL MEAN HIS CLOSEST PEOPLE
AROUND HIM TO UNDERMINED HIM.
THEY HAVE THE MAJORITY IN TH